so what's this really all about here
debate ben shapiro daily wire
editor-in-chief and host of the Ben
Shapiro election special right here on
Fox and code pink national director
Ariel gold who was at the court today
protesting ban let's start with you
your take on this emotional day but were
the facts advanced in order to bolster
MS Ford's credibility they weren't I
mean there was no corroborate of
evidence provided not one single shred
not one single iota that doesn't mean
that Ford didn't tell a credible story
doesn't mean that her story wasn't
emotionally resonant but it does mean
that we can't simply destroy a man's
life and career based on an
uncorroborated allegation no matter how
much we have sympathy for the person
making the allegation and there was not
one shred of supporting evidence that
was brought to back her account
Cavanaugh's denials were just as sincere
they were just as emotionally affecting
and I don't see any reason to suggest by
the way the evidence is more on his side
than it is on her so I don't see any
reason to suggest the Cavanaugh's
nomination ought to end based on what
happened today
Ariel were you happy with the Democrats
performance because it didn't seem to be
a bolstering her factual remember
remembrance of what happened it seemed
more like a bunch of little speeches
let's remember that this is a life long
appointment and don't we want somebody
for this appointment who is
squeaky-clean somebody that we are not
debating maybe they had a severe
drinking problem to the point of
blacking out and maybe they grossly
sexually assault numerous women so you
so you're saying that at this point
there was more factual evidence
presented today to make an
uncorroborated allegation enough to
destroy a man's entire future well let's
first of all remain with you like that
if that happened to you or if someone
came forward and said Ariel Oh xxx
you're too young but let's 15 years ago
Ariel actually pushed me down a
staircase and no one was in the house
but she knows she did it and I was so
traumatized that I couldn't talk about
it and all you can say is I've never
even been at a party with this woman and
she can't produce anyone who was at a
party with her wouldn't you be mad at
this hearing today if you were at a
similar Inquisition about getting a job
and people were not believing you and
saying you were angry about
feuding the charge wouldn't you be angry
at what point in history do we begin
believing women about the problems that
we will never live country and in this
world with sexual as well women never
mistake their attackers and their
identities that never have word actually
begin to disclose as early as 2012 we
didn't get the know far before right
Arielle I'm really glad you came on but
we didn't get those notes been here is
that your as a fact though women are
watching women do vote and women a lot
of women have gotten really jacked up
and excited about this me too movement
because they feel like it's their time
they're heard they're taken seriously
finally so how do the Republicans way
that as they proceed with regardless of
whatever happens with this confirmation
vote I think they simply have to state
over and over and over again that trust
but verify is still the policy with
regard to allegations a mere allegation
alone is not justifying of repercussions
in an allegation is not the end of the
story you can believe the woman and
still recognize that you must have
corroborate of evidence before you
destroy somebody's life otherwise mirror
allegations are the end of the story and
that's not a world anybody wants to live
in it's fascinating to watch so many
folks on the Left who are deeply
concerned most of the time with
defendants right suddenly truck that all
out the window when it comes to a
specific type of allegation with the
specific type of person being alleged to
have committed this particular crime